oh boy
this one's gonna be a doozy hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by aura and
we'll be reviewing ex-biggest loser
personal trainer jillian michaels but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
aura as you guys know i have struggled
with anxiety and insomnia for
pretty much my entire life so i have
tried a lot of different techniques to
unwind but i recently discovered an
award-winning mindfulness and sleep app
called aura which has been used by over
5 million people to date and it's made a
huge difference in my day so aura
includes thousands of amazing
meditations and stories plus playlists
on cbt
life coaching and spirituality depending
on your needs and relaxation style this
isn't like other one-size-fits-all apps
because you fill out a short quiz which
will then give you personalized tracks
based on your anxiety and sleep needs my
favorite section of the app is their
morning meditations for better
productivity and concentration which has
really helped to set my intentions and
deal with my decision fatigue on busy
days so if you want to explore some new
self-care strategies check out the link
in my description box for a seven day
free trial of aura plus 25 off of your
first year subscription also of course
be sure to read my disclaimer including
a big big big trigger warning
jillian isn't exactly known to sugarcoat
diet advice so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey and if you are new here
ring that bell so that you never miss
out on a video all right folks as a
quick little introduction jillian
michaels is basically the og fitness
influencer and has made her mark in the
fitness industry through media
appearances on talk shows and tv shows
most notably her stint on the biggest
loser she's also released countless
fitness books and dvds posts her own
podcast and even has a highly rated
fitness app so yeah the girl stays busy
even though jillian is basically a
household name in the fitness industry
she has come into some hot water for her
controversial tough love approach to
weight loss and dieting are you ready to
work
are you ready to work there's honestly a
lot of stuff that i could discuss when
it comes to jillian but i'm really
trying to keep these videos shorter so
today i'm gonna focus on her latest what
i in a day video and when i say latest i
mean at the time of filming which as you
guys know is far in advance so who knows
she could have an updated one since i
filmed this let's take a look i'm the
common sense diet i don't overeat i eat
all three macronutrients and i try to
avoid processed food 80 of the time i
try to make 80 of my food choices good
ones and 20 of my food choices are not
so great ah and that keeps me sane okay
so i know the 80 20 rule is more of a
colloquialism at this point than an
absolute percentage split but i still
never loved the concept myself because i
do think it dichotomizes food into good
and bad categories like even processed
food should not be so easily divided i'm
not sure if she knows this but yogurt
wine bread canned beans all healthy
foods that she mentions in this video
are actually considered processed foods
having said that i think of having
structure like this helps to keep her
sane while also ensuring that she can
maintain her fitness goals because yes i
acknowledge that fitness is kind of her
livelihood then i think that this
definitely does make some sense and if
it works for her it works for me i eat
complex carbohydrates with lots of fiber
whole grains beans legumes fruits
vegetables i eat
healthy fats polyunsaturated
monounsaturated and a little bit of
saturated fat not a ton but i get some
my protein is ideally wild caught fish
grass-fed grass finished beef i don't
really compromise on that okay
lots to discuss here first of all i
really love that jillian is talking
about getting in all her macros and
she's focusing on high quality sources
as well higher fiber carbs like she
mentioned are energizing and promote
better regularity satiety blood sugar
control and heart health ditto for
polyunsaturated fats and monounsaturated
fats over saturated fats now as for an
occasional grass-fed beef meal i
actually think that that's a great
choice i mean i think we can all stand
to reduce our reliance on red meat and
if you do choose to incorporate red meat
into your diet to do so sparingly as for
the grass-fed versus conventional
grain-fed argument a grass-fed beef will
contain about five times more omega-3s
and twice the conjugated linoleic acid
or cla content which is also associated
with reduced risk of heart disease and
obesity and while it is generally more
expensive to go this route i think if
you're limiting your intake to a once a
month burger you can perhaps be a little
bit more splurgy it's a hamburger made
out of meat on a bun with nothing i
really try to get wild cut fish sockeye
salmon in particular all of the great
nutrients and the omega-3s that come
from wild salmon especially things like
salmon there are some things that are
okay farmed but a lot of it has food dye
and a bunch of garbage like
read about it first of all
i want to start by saying any salmon
wild or farmed is a nutrient-dense
choice rich in heart-healthy omega-3s
that alone gets
thumbs up from me but if you want to
break down further i would say that wild
salmon is considered nutritionally
superior because it has slightly more
calcium and iron less total fat and
saturated fat and a better omega-3 to
six ratio it also has slightly fewer
calories compared to farmed now there's
also concern that farmed salmon contains
higher amounts of contaminants like pcbs
and dioxins but these compounds are
ultimately found in both and the current
consensus is that the health benefits of
consuming fish definitely outweigh the
risk now mercury levels are generally
low in all salmon so that's not
particularly a concern but antibiotic
use in some fish farm regions continue
to be a big problem canada for example
has worked very hard to reduce their
antibiotic use whereas chile which is
the world's second largest producer of
farmed salmon still relies heavily on
antibiotics so if you're choosing a
farmed salmon product ideally you want
to look for a product that's been
certified by a regulatory organization
for example
look for aquaculture stewardship council
global sustainable seafood initiative or
the monterey bay aquarium seafood watch
cage-free organic eggs okay i'm just
gonna intercept here because i'm hearing
the o word a lot and not the good big o
that we really like
that's what she said
i'm talking about
organics now this is such a complicated
debate and i think it's merit really
depends on the food category and also
where the food is being sourced i don't
associate with anyone who eats
conventional food i'm in a social class
above that but for a very quick overview
i actually discussed this in a little
bit more detail in my sorel amore video
right here now in the case of eggs it
does feel like there are so many
qualifying terms now that it can feel
very overwhelming in the grocery store i
came here for the same reason people go
to the zoo caged eggs are eggs that very
simply put come from hens that are not
caged according to the usda the hens can
freely roam a building room or enclosed
area but do not have access to the
outdoors if that was your preference you
would want to be looking for free range
and or pasture fed which is not a
regulated term but organic eggs are from
cage-free hens who have some access to
the outdoors and who are fed an organic
diet free of conventional pesticides and
fertilizers are these specialty eggs
healthier than conventional well when
cbc marketplace tested a variety of
conventional and organic options here in
canada they found that while organics
did have more omega-3s than conventional
there otherwise weren't any major
nutritional differences but if you're
concerned about humanely raised hens my
suggestion would be to get to know a
local farmer and buy directly from them
i do
organic grass-fed yogurt okay
intercepting again because again organic
and in this case grass-fed as well which
like i mentioned before it does have a
slight nutritional benefit over
conventional dairy so grass-fed dairy
tends to have higher amounts of omega-3s
and cla and lower amounts of omega-6 and
saturated fat palmitic acid now organic
dairy does differ from conventional at
least in the states in that it's
produced without any antibiotics or
added hormones now obviously these
attributes come at an added price but i
just want people to know that both
conventionally produced and organically
produced dairy is considered safe
ultimately this comes down to budget and
personal preference like there's an
organic cheeto um i'm not getting paid
for this it's called luke's luke's
lightning bolts it doesn't have a ton of
chemicals in it so if i have like a half
a cup of it with a sandwich or a salad
the world's not gonna end right is it
health food no is it gonna fight cancer
no is it gonna cause it i mean not if
you eat a tiny bit of it this is where
the argument for organics feels a little
shaky to me it's called the natural
fallacy the belief that just because
something is more natural that it gets a
free pass it's like the mom who calls
oreos poison what kind of poison did you
use
dwight i didn't poison you i was kidding
but will buy her kid organic
cream-filled chocolate cookie sandwiches
no problem i'm not demonizing cookies of
any variety but
they're still cookies now also i want to
make it clear that i'm not demonizing
these cheetos these sound amazing and
totally something that i would buy and i
agree they're not going to cause cancer
not even if you eat the whole bag it's
not going to cause cancer on its own but
you know what
neither is this when we compare the
ingredients in the organic cheetos
versus like a regular cheetos we can see
that the organic ones do not contain any
food dye so that may be important to you
if you are allergic or if you want to
avoid looking like a chain smoker
now the organic cheetos also contain
some real cheese in addition to the
cheese flavor in there which again might
actually rule these out if you're
concerned about artificial flavors but
otherwise when comparing the organic
versus regular cheetos both have
basically the same amount of fiber and
protein and almost the same amount of
calories so despite the health halo no
cheeto is going to fight cancer like she
says nor will they single-handedly cause
cancer either even if you eat more than
a tiny bit of it or if you eat the
non-organic version so i say choose a
snack that you enjoy and eat it in the
context of a balanced diet which it does
sound like she does it's just too bad
that it seems to come with so much moral
baggage generally it's about four drinks
a week topped and i do red wine white
wine and sake don't really do much else
because i want the health benefits if
i'm gonna drink and i drink in
moderation because
studies have shown us that up to a glass
a night or six drinks a week have health
benefits okay so obviously i agree it's
a good call to drink in moderation
i don't know where i felt i could get a
little drink around here do you but and
she is right that most of the literature
suggests that light to moderate drinking
has some health benefits but heavy
drinking has health risks now i don't
think that this research is reason to
start drinking if you don't already
drink because there are way more
nutrient dense ways in your diet to get
those same benefits but if you're
enjoying a few drinks a week i don't see
a huge concern i don't overeat i balance
the amount of calories i take in with
the amount of calories i put out so i
eat about 1800 calories a day if i work
out particularly hard i eat 2 000
calories that day well if i've worked
out extra hard i can eat a little bit
more i can have the treat food um
so
i'd say that 1800 to 2000 calories a day
sounds likely adequate enough for
jillian's needs and she may even need a
bit more than that depending on her
physical activity now while i want to
trust that jillian knows her body best
and will provide it with the fuel that
it needs this is her profession she has
also made some controversial comments
about intuitive eating that i'm going to
talk about in a minute and also about
discussing manipulating her weight down
to a very specific number i don't know i
have to question how in tune she
actually is with her true needs also i
don't know who needs to hear this but
you can still have a
treat food even if you didn't work out
extra hard i just don't think it's
healthy to be thinking about everything
in our day as this kind of transaction
you know add the
have a couple bites of my kids
mac and cheese it's okay oh gosh
feel really sad for people who worry so
much about others validation and
appraisal of their diet that they need
to justify having a bite of their kids
food to absolute strangers and honestly
i feel worse for people who have small
enough lives that they actually give
jillian my dear no one will judge you
for eating non-organic mac and cheese i
wouldn't even judge you for eating a
whole box
like there are a lot of bites that make
up a day to be worrying about what
everyone thinks about each and every one
i generally eat same three things for
breakfast i'll have either eggs
scrambled eggs with a little bit of
organic cheese or eggs over easy with
two pieces of organic whole grain toast
eggs with veggies or eggs with a little
bit of fruit on the side but i'm getting
protein fat carbs right if we were to
take a shot
every single time jillian said the word
organic i'm not sure i'd make it to the
end of this video
oh my god but honestly playing the
organic card in every breath is starting
to feel a bit more like an elitist flex
than a teachable moment and i'm not
feeling it i'd like to tell you about
the benefits of eating organic i'm not
interested but i will say organic or not
this breakfast does sound solid like she
says we've got some protein and fat from
the eggs and the cheese and carbs from
the toast and fruit for my lunch i'll
usually do protein salad it could be
like a taco salad for example maybe with
shrimp so it has the black beans the
shrimp some salsa on top all my veggies
mixed in occasionally i'll have a
sandwich but it could be even grilled
fish tacos i'm low-key a little relieved
that we didn't hear the big o word here
but i'm sure there's more of that to
come having said that these are all
great options for lunch because like she
says she's all about hitting all three
macros at most meals and while she
didn't specifically mention like sources
of fat i would definitely be adding in
like some guac to those tacos or salad
and maybe a nice little pesto or cheese
to the sandwich for a snack um i'll
usually have an apple i don't really
like almond butter i recommend it
because it's good for you but i don't
really like it so i have organic peanut
butter like an apple peanut butter or
like piece of fruit and an organic
cheese stick a little bit of trail mix
some dry roasted nuts and a piece of
fruit but basically again the protein
fat and carbs i keep it super simple
first of all it makes me kind of sad to
hear almost like the embarrassment and
shame in her voice when she admits to
eating or liking something that doesn't
conform to her food rules like a bite of
her kids mac and cheese or in this case
the peanut butter folks
peanut butter is great
it's actually an all-in-one hunger
crushing combo and it has more protein
than other nut butters i don't know why
everyone demonizes it but the girl
obviously does know how to build a
balanced snack and ultimately i'm just
glad she's not forcing herself to eat
something that she hates and dinner same
like tonight i'm gonna go get sushi so
what am i gonna have i'm gonna have uh
yellowtail sashimi with jalapeno i'm
gonna have uh probably six pieces of
sockeye salmon sushi i'm going to have a
seaweed salad um i do get the spicy tuna
roll they tell them no mayo and then
when i go for something like chi food
i'll split a soft shell crabble
i love sushi because i think it's
inherently quite balanced with the fat
and the protein in the fish and the
carbs and the rice but do we really need
to call
half of a soft shell crab roll cheap
food now aside from the fact that we
have got to stop moralizing foods with
this language
if you're doing it stop it a half of a
soft shell crab roll has like 150
calories i think we're gonna be okay
if you have the whole roll
as your alleged cheat food
this is exhausting i eat every three to
four hours and i create a minimum of a
12 hour fast one and i try to get
at least a 12 hour window but i aim for
14 and i do cheat it i have organic cold
brewed coffee in the morning as i cheat
the fasting window from 12 hours to 14
with heavy whipping cream and you don't
break
the benefits of that overnight fast uh
are you gonna tell her
or am i
cause that
will actually break a fast it might not
kick you out of ketosis but most of the
benefits of ketosis aren't actually seen
on super short overnight bouts like this
as it usually takes two to four days to
get into ketosis to begin with also
heavy whipping cream while high in fat
still contains small amounts of protein
and carbs there's a lot of things wrong
with this little hack
[Music]
also some research suggests that you can
still reap the alleged benefits of
intermittent fasting in a modest 12-hour
fast so i would say rather than trying
to push yourself into an arbitrary
14-hour fast with whipping cream i don't
know just eat that's my eating schedule
which is really important by the way
because if you're grazing all day long
your blood sugar is always high you want
that overnight window where your body is
not breaking down food so it can do
housekeeping i think what jillian is
referring to is the migratory motor
complex which i mentioned in my sibo and
sam ozkerel videos here and here now the
mmc is like a broom that helps move food
particles through the digestive tract
every 130 minutes or so so you don't
actually need to wait five whole hours
between meals it's more like two and a
half to trigger this natural cleansing
response and if you're having trouble
with blood sugar management make sure
that you're focusing on the hunger
crushing combo you don't need to be
holding back on eating between meals if
you're hungry unnecessarily try to avoid
the refined sugars and
processed grains and all that crap drink
in moderation
and i promise you'll be fine man does
anyone else find her healthy eating is
so easy stop complaining vibe like super
condescending i mean i also acknowledge
that i have no lived experience in a
larger body but at least i'm not over
here suggesting that manipulating your
body is an obvious walk in the park so
let's talk about my overall thoughts on
jillian's diet now while jillian coins
her diet as the common sense diet i
would argue that her way of eating is
actually not that common at all that is
unless you're a whole foods groupie that
can afford to eat exclusively organic
grass-fed cage-free and wild-caught
foods while shaming yourself over a
single bite of organic mac and cheese or
cheese puffs
even though her diet sounds very well
balanced and nutritious of course it's
actually wildly inaccessible for most
people it's also interesting to me that
even though she claims to follow the 80
20 rule to keep her sane she still holds
quite a bit of shame when she does give
herself permission to eat treat foods
even if they are organic or something
highly nutritious like peanut butter
it's as if she can't just let herself
eat a cookie or donut as is without some
sort of health halo around it to justify
it with that said it's really no
surprise to me that she dishes out diet
culture rhetoric like referring to meals
as cheats or garbage or suggesting that
you need to earn your food through
exercise or demonizing inorganic
processed foods so while her body
language and tone feels super chill and
relaxed if you listen to the words
coming out of her mouth it's clear to me
that she's actually remarkably
restrained and given her controversial
commentary on intuitive eating which
largely missed the mark it's my feeling
that jillian can't really comprehend a
relationship with food beyond dieting
and weight loss for example in her video
about intuitive eating she constantly
describes food and movement from the
lens of seeing results and not so much
as something that is to be enjoyed or
make your body feel good in her eyes
giving yourself unconditional permission
to eat the foods that you enjoy is a
sign of lacking self-control she also
denies that diet culture even exists and
that our health aka size comes down to
willpower in other words your size is a
you problem and is something that needs
fixing houston we have a problem so it's
really no surprise that she's hell-bent
on suggesting that someone's size
determines their health and that someone
in a larger body can't possibly be
metabolically healthy and while i don't
want to discredit jillian's expertise as
i do know that she is a highly
knowledgeable voice in the fitness space
i personally find her patronizing
language around weight loss really
difficult to swallow not gonna say it
again she has a tendency to overly
simplify weight loss and wellness with a
real condescending tone as if you should
feel guilty or dumb for not already
following these simple rules as if it's
your fault that you can't be thin
because hey this is common sense i
especially found it frustrating that she
attempted to dumb down losing the last
10 pounds to what she describes as a few
simple steps like drinking more water
sleeping eight hours and cutting out
booze which she said that alone will get
it done um raise your hand if you drink
a ton of water and you still don't look
like her
jillian my dear you need a reality check
but i guess this is also the jillian
michaels who is caught on camera
motivating her clients by telling them
that you can't stop unless you faint
puke or die not my style but appeals to
someone apparently honestly i could rant
all day but i will save it for part two
if you guys want so on that note that is
all that i have for you today thank you
again to aura for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to this channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you